hi I'm Finn from stranger things and I'm
Caleb McLaughlin and this is the last
thing I did her muffle the heart the bot
and the hand which I don't I don't even
use them but maybe I've used it twice oh
that face the laughing and I don't
really know explain it like like nervous
not really nervous but like I think I
did something wrong face I snapshotted
uh my friend ja he when he was a little
kid cuz I wanted to show him cuz I
wanted to roast him look at this face he
looks like adorable little baby
there's Mina Stanley well guys Stanley
was playing call of duty with my friend
Dane and he lost so he said I could hit
him with a golf ball or a ping pong ball
so uh yesterday I did a pink ball event
I got shot in the thigh twice and like
on the ohlet's hip on my ear Erin so
much YouTube you know I'm the weirdo I
don't go straight to YouTube I look up
on Google YouTube and then I went to go
play the song I was just jamming up on
to Jody Seay forever my lady
[Music]
okay it's a joke here even stranger
things I got to get my act together and
then a picture of Joe I was actually
listening to bump into vote barn be will
always have a place in my heart not the
army today I love army today but I
really really love army from the
eighties it just makes me feel good
it was Sonic Unleashed goofy rubbery
swinging arms by game grumps which is a
YouTube channel huge game upside yeah so
I have two alarms I took long showers
my last alarm was to get out of the
shower so I wouldn't have those little
like those what do you call them the
like one might when you're fitting the
tip of your fingers get soft
pruney yes yeah so I had to get out of
there this is any key I don't know if
that's like a type of it just that's
what it says maybe it's because it o is
because I had to go into like a lawyer
thing I didn't know how to pronounce the
name so I just passed out like I did say
it I don't want to I don't know what
that meant but it says I don't want to
will ever know what that means
I don't